Evan we're going to Mexico yeah this is
where we met we didn't expect that we
will get on this this is apparently the
second best ride in um in Epcot
everything is better with anina
good morning good morning good morning
let's have a magical day today is the
Epcot day Epcot we Evan has planned a
lot a ride
let's hope that we get it because it
seems very tight it's a tight schedule
today I like things tight
okay
all right let's go have fun in Epcot
[Music]
all right we are here they open let's go
let's go Evan why are you standing here
I'm ready
[Music]
first up we're gonna go watch the Frozen
show I'm sweating guys
hot day again today
all right Audrey this is this
um
Frozen ride yeah
[Music]
the Frozen ride was quite fun
next next up we're off to um Galaxy of
Guardian this is
okay yep yep okay let's go the best ride
of the um best ride of the echo right
now Echo Epcot it's okay let's go
[Music]
okay we are here at the guardian of the
galaxy it looks very cool as I'm gonna
show you guys
foreign
[Music]
the ride is fun but I feel a little
nauseous I don't know if it's because I
didn't really sleep well last night so I
get really nauseous and dizzy but it was
really good it's really good oh I forgot
to mention when we went to the right it
just it's just the boys and I Evan and
Catherine went to the to meet Mulan I
was gonna say Mulan they're gonna they
went to meet Mulan so we're done before
then we're gonna pick up some coffee and
meet up with them
next up we're going to go to
um living with the land
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just had out and then Evan woke up
this morning like early this morning to
book the Ratatouille at seven seven
o'clock shark he booked it but now 11 30
it says that it was closed so that's
Bonkers anyways we're gonna Evan's gonna
find us a spot to eat lunch and then
we'll figure out what to do
okay we're gonna go to Yorkshire country
fish shop for their famous fish and
chips in Epcot
[Music]
the food is good but but we sweat our
face up it was so hot sitting outside
they don't have indoor dining we're
gonna stop by this door just to get some
air conditioning to cool it down
[Music]
I was supposed to go to the segment that
we're gonna go to the short film right
now get some air conditioning
how you feeling I'm feeling so much
better now because I see yeah all right
the short film was fun to watch I had a
good laugh kids had a good laugh it was
nice to see Nina laughs more at kids
movies than the kids
we like it all right next up the fickman
ride
foreign
[Music]
all right let's go what's the next one
that is
what's the next one Evan what uh we'll
go to the water let's see what aquariums
in the Nemo right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Evan and the kids are going to the
mission space right I'm gonna sit out
and chill all right
yeah it's adult time let's go have fun
foreign
like I always said I would be Commander
it was a little bit bumpy yeah it's a
little bit bumpy but she got us back to
Earth safely good job oh yeah all right
they had a good time yeah
at the mission right is it mission right
[Music]
next next one we're going to the Mexico
Mexico
will be a nice peaceful ride and then
we're going to Mexico yeah this is where
we met up the stairs the stairs I think
it was my pickup line what's a nice girl
like you doing in a place like this yeah
something like that something like that
yeah yeah it's still true it's on these
stairs right here yeah oh who's this
hello
what's your name
huh imagine meeting you in a place like
this
all right we're done in Mexico moving on
to what France to get some ice cream get
some ice cream and get my last postcard
is that your last one yeah let's go
all right we had a ride in Paris
we're gonna try to see if we can make it
to the Ratatouille one
we didn't expect that we will get on
this this is apparently the second best
ride in um in Epcot so thank you Evan
for checking and we made it in
[Music]
all right the Ratatouille ride was fun
they like this the new rides that they
had for this year it's it's actually
really well done wait I had a good time
they had the kids had a good time it's
good right Evan oh yeah do you like it
very well done yeah especially when you
have a Nina with you everything is
better with anina
[Music]
all right this is the famous ice cream
place they have 16 flavors and you could
add alcohol to your ice cream too
[Music]
good stuff
Jeffrey Catherine too good
[Music]
cheers love
yummy good all right next on Morocco for
Catherine to pick up the postcard
[Music]
all right next trip we're going to Japan
[Music]
ready guys
[Music]
Germany
[Music]
Catherine yeah Catherine you got all the
11 uh all the 11 cards yeah it means you
travel all these countries in
you got two wow so nice of her right
yeah yeah all right time to go home now
and also if the people who don't believe
me I'm gonna show them this that I went
to Disney World and we had this video
too right yeah okay time to go home
welcome home Catherine
well actually you're not even born in
China cheers Welcome Home to me I I'm
born in China
all right one last ride before we go
home
what is it mission
space of Earth
thank you
it was pouring hard oh my God
yeah crazy so we waited a little bit
inside it wasn't going away so we ran to
the car
luckily we kind of remembered where we
parked yeah drove home and then
everybody showered got out of the wet
clothes had an amazing meal that Nina
cooked watch A Stranger Things episode
and now they're in bed because I gotta
wake up early to go to Hollywood Studios
day four of Disney if you want to see
what we do there this video right there
next to us go cook it we'll see you
there I need to believe